c'est l'un des attraits touristiques de
la commune mais l'église de seconde on a
besoin de faire peau neuve
le plus gros problème urgent this is mme
c'est celui de l'étanchéité des toitures
et la réfection des enduits puisqu'ils
sont en train de se déchausser les
pierres commencent à tomber
et ça pose un réel problème de sécurité
les toitures sont à refaire
l'une des cloches sera restauré le tout
coûtera 350 mille euros financé à 50%
par l'état et 10 % par le département la
commune paiera 150 mille euros via un
emprunt qu'elle complètera par une
souscription lancée avec la fondation du
patrimoine
on a d'ailleurs de nombreux donateurs
qui ont déjà privé qui ont qui ont donc
donné et par la suite on espère bien
toucher les industriels tous les acteurs
du génois du grand chênois pour nous
aider à atteindre un objectif qui est de
dix mille deux cents euros qui nous
permettra également d'être abondée par
la fondation du patrimoine la commune
doit son nom à l'archevêque godon un
ermite du 6e siècle l'église s'est
développée sur les reliques du saint
on a ramené son corps ici à savon dont
on l'a ramené dans un chariot qui
étaient tirées par des boeufs est arrivé
au pied de l'église en barres 1d buzz à
à fouiller le sol avec sa patte et a
fait jaillir une source
alors évidemment on a pensé que c'était
une sorte de miracle et que la source
allait être une miraculeuse construit à
partir du neuvième siècle le bâtiment
s'est dégradée avec le temps en
subissant plusieurs incendies en 1570
lors de la guerre de renault lors des
guerres de religion
elle fut incendiée par les calvinistes
qui était m à 52 ans et puis ensuite
elle a suivi des dégâts au moment de la
révolution est là étaient des pavés les
mobiliers ont été incendiés les statuts
ont été dégradés
les travaux devraient durer d'avril
jusqu'à cet été pour l'heure 3600 euros
ont été récoltés